al grito de no retrocederemos los
manifestantes protagonizaron un tenso
enfrentamiento mientras marchaban hacia
el cuartel general de la policía algunos
prendieron fuego a los coches aparcados
y destrozaron los escaparates lo que
llevó a las autoridades a imponer un
toque de queda el motín de que no se en
wisconsin se dio después de otro caso de
aparente uso excesivo de la fuerza
policial contra ciudadanos negros
estamos cansados de esto y en este
momento esta es la generación equivocada
a la que le ocurre esto la frustración
está hirviendo hasta arriba y estamos
enojados y cansados un usuario de
twitter publicó este vídeo filmado el
domingo por la tarde en el se ve a un
hombre negro custodiado por la policía
aunque parece que no obedece sus órdenes
mientras se metía en el vehículo
un policía le disparó por la espalda
siete veces el hombre fue identificado
como jake blake de 29 años según la
policía de que los agentes respondieron
a lo que describieron como un incidente
doméstico los medios locales citaron a
la prometida de play asegurando que el
tiroteo ocurrió frente a sus tres hijos
sin ningún motivo el gobernador del
estado tony hibbert en un tuit mordaz
aseguró que la víctima no era el primer
hombre negro en recibir disparos ni en
ser herido o asesinado sin piedad a
manos de los encargados de hacer cumplir
la ley en eeuu